شكرًا لك، على
بعد حوالي 15 ميلًا من
خط المواجهة الأمامي للهجوم المضاد، أعضاء
لواء المشاة 128 موجودون هنا
للتدريب، وهم الذين يقومون
بالقتال في الخطوط الأمامية
الذين يتدربون هنا لمدة يومين أو ثلاثة أيام
بعد ذلك يعودون مباشرة إلى
الخط الأمامي ثم يبقون هناك لمدة
ثلاثة إلى أربعة ثم يقومون بالدورة
مرة أخرى
نعم نحن مستعدون نحن ننتظر هذا [
موسيقى]
ما تشاهده الآن هو أنني
أتدرب بالفعل على اقتحام الانتخابات
وهذا ما يفعلونه  سيذهب بالفعل
للسيطرة على خندق العدو،
وبعضهم يرتدي أشعة الليزر على
ستراتهم المضادة للرصاص وعندما
تضيء أشعة الليزر فهذا يعني أنهم ماتوا.
كان يعمل في متجر تجزئة عبر الإنترنت قبل
الحرب بعد القتال في العام الماضي،
وهو الآن  المدرب
مهم جدًا حتى بالنسبة للدفاع، فأنت
تعرف بالفعل تكتيكات عدوك
وما سيفعلونه في
خط المواجهة بالطبع ضخم ولكن
معظم القتال يحدث في
مساحات صغيرة بشكل لا يصدق تمامًا مثل هذه
على طول خطوط الأشجار على الخطوط
الأمامية للهجوم المضاد  ما
يفعله هؤلاء الجنود هو في الواقع
التدرب على مد أسلاك العطل باستخدام
القنابل اليدوية في النهاية، وهذا هو ما يجري في
الكثير من القتال الآن سواء من الناحية
الهجومية أو الدفاعية للعثور على
أسلاك العطل هذه ووضعها،
نعم لقد رأيناها ولكن لم يتم ضبطها
بواسطة محترفين، إذا نصبها محترفون،
فمن المستحيل رؤيتهم
مع دوي المدفعية ذات العجلات على
المسافة التي تتدرب عليها هذه القوات.
يأتون إلى الغابة
ويتدربون لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانهم العثور على تلك
الفخاخ ويتدربون لمعرفة ما إذا
كانوا سيعيشون أم لا.  مت،
سمعت الانفجار، ترى
الدخان، هذا هو التدريب على إلقاء قنبلة يدوية وهو
شيء يتدربون عليه
هنا ولكن في غضون يومين فقط على
خط المواجهة سيكون الواقع المرير،
إنها حقيقة أن كل هؤلاء الرجال
يحتضنون رجالًا مثل فلاد هو  كان
مدرسًا للتاريخ ولم ير عائلته منذ
عام والتزامه
نعم أفتقدهم وأريد حقًا
رؤيتهم ولكن ليس لاحقًا بعد قليل من
انتصارنا